Why? Why in the Quran Jesus included and
why do they praise him? The Muslims kind
of all love Jesus, right?
>> Well, yeah. Yes and no. What it is is so
Islam is the new religion, right? Is
Muhammad comes and Judaism exists.
Christianity exists. The two are tied
together, right? Jesus is a Jew. The New
Testament talks about the Old Testament.
You know, there's a continuity in there.
And then you have the this Arab guy in
in Arabia. So what Muhammad did is he
appropriated
to give legitimacy to his movement. He
had to connect himself to Judaism,
Christianity because that's what
everyone knew. That is the those are the
traditional names that that have the
weight of antiquity. Abraham, Moses,
Jesus. So who's this guy name?
>> Yeah. So he has to bring them in. So
what he did is he used them and he said
yeah of course they're all true and we
love them but he recast them and made
them such so that they were basically
promoting with him. So basically Jesus
was came to earth primarily to tell us
about the pariclete and the paricletes
the holy spirit but it's a Greek word
which means the comforter. According to
Muslims the comforter is Muhammad. So
Jesus came to proclaim Muhammad and
everything was turned around. So yes,
Abraham is good and he's a prophet and
and everyone's a prophet. Jesus is a
prophet. So Muslims believe a lot of the
people who want you to, you know, think
that there's a, you know, dialogue or
there's some sort of commonality between
Muslims and Christians say what you just
said. You know, they love Jesus. They
believe he was born of a virgin, that he
was sinless, that he was perfect, that
he performed miracles. That all sounds
great, but they reject the cardinal
teachings of Christ. They reject he's
the son of God. They reject he was
crucified. They reject he was
resurrected. He didn't die for mankind's
sin. So the really important things that
they reject but again it's always taking
them to give themselves some sort of
legitimacy and saying yes we're part of
that old ancient heritage of Judaism
Christianity but then they are rewritten
in a different way which is very
different incidentally from what
Christians do. So obviously Christians
and Jews are very are different because
Christians believe in Christ and Jews
don't. Um but what's interesting is
Christians took what we call the Old
Testament, the Jewish scriptures as they
are. So if you look at the Bible, right,
and you have the Old Testament, that is
the same books that the Jews have
>> to.
>> Yeah. Yeah. From Genesis all the way to
I think Malachi or Okay. They have the
same books and the Christians did not
change them. Now they may Christians
have their own interpretation. So
Abraham now is no longer the father of
Israel is now Christians. So there's
interpretational changes, but the text
is the same. What Muhammad did and what
Muslims do is completely different. Is
they said the Old Testament and the New
Testament, the way it's written is
wrong. And Muhammad is here to give us
the new version. So he claims them, but
he changes who they are and what they
said. So Jesus, um, like I said, he's
actually a prophet, and he's here to
proclaim the same thing that Muhammad
is. And when he comes back on
resurrection day, and he will uh he's
going to break all the crosses and kill
all the pigs because uh he's like
Muhammad and that's all. So you see it's
all rewritten in a way to validate
Islam. All right.
>> So in Islam, Jesus when he comes back
for the second time, he's he's going to
judge. Yeah. So if they say that Jesus
is not the son of God and he is not the
God himself, then how can he judge on
the judgment day? If only God can judge.
I may I may not be correct about if he's
going to judge, but he's known to be
part of the judgment day. He's part of
es the is, you know, the Islamic
esquetology end days. Um but his exact
role, like I said, primarily it's to
tell Christians how they are wrong. So
he's going to break the cross. He's
going to kill the pigs and he's going to
cancel Jiza. Jiz was the way Christians
could remain Christians is they pay
tribute. So now by canceling Jiz it
means you can't even you can't even be a
Christian. You have to become a true
Muslim because Jesus is a Muslim in the
Islamic rendering Isa. But as far the as
the judgment issue, I'm not really sure.
>> What's the problem with the pigs?
[laughter]
>> I don't know. Muhammad didn't dig on
swine.